welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Marvel Studios has confirmed
that the Netflix Marvel series are Canon
their history officially part of the
Sacred timeline which plays a big role
in the Echo series and presumably in the
upcoming Daredevil born again this is a
huge admission by the studio which has
historically been reluctant to embrace
the Netflix Daredevil and Jessica Jones
Luke Cage Iron Fist Defenders Punisher
all these series as existing within the
MCU continuity even if these shows all
took steps to align with the events of
the MCU and the years following the
Battle of New York and in the heads of
many if not most of the people who
watched and enjoyed those shows they
were part of the MCU so for a lot of
them this confirmation was like well
yeah duh we already knew that and
hopefully it brings a bit of vindication
to a certain subset of angry people on
Twitter but for those of you who didn't
watch or maybe don't remember all 13
seasons of those Netflix shows from 2015
to 2019 what all is included in this
widened landscape like in terms of
precise runtime how much bigger is the
MCU now than what some viewers
previously thought it was and what Loose
Ends did these shows leave us that that
future Marvel Studios titles will now be
expected to pick up by the way all five
episodes of Marvel's Echo are being
broken down on this channel with amazing
detail by Jessica Clemens and guys I am
learning so much from these videos I am
completely blown away by the depth Jess
is going to give these videos a watch
and wish her a happy belated birthday
okay before the episodes of echo were
dropped executive producer Brad wibom
who is Marvel's head of streaming
television and animation he's part of
Kevin V's Inner Circle Brain Trust he
made this confirmation to Screen Rant
now I have a question about Daredevil is
everything that happened on the Netflix
series a part of the Sacred timeline or
is it not so I can say that we've been
we've been up until this point we've
been a little bit KY about what's sacred
timeline what's not sacred timeline that
was that was born of frankly a period at
the studio where we were like we have to
stick the landing with Avengers sure you
know we it was it was another part of
the company developing the Netflix stuff
we were aware of what they were doing
they were aware of what we were doing
but it it it was It was a it was it was
a lot it was a lot to balance anyway but
now that you know some time has passed
now that we see how actually how well
integrated the stories are um I think
that I personally Brad windbound would
be confident and saying it is part of
the Sacred time okay so spoiler warning
for all of the echo series coming up the
series did double down on the Netflix
continuity with preseason promos using
footage of Kingpin from the Netflix
Daredevil series and in Echo episode 4
Wilson Fisk offered as a gift to Maya
Lopez the hammer he used to kill his
father when Wilson Fisk was a boy and in
episode five we saw flashbacks in
Wilson's memory of him standing in front
of a painting and remembering his
childhood trauma of staring at the paint
peeling from the wall while his father
abused his mother to be clear the hammer
is not the same hammer and the room
where young Wilson stared at the peeling
paint was not his bedroom with a Yankee
pen it and Daredevil it was a room
adjacent to the dining room now I would
say hey maybe the paint throughout the
apartment was chipping but it was that
specific wall that seemed to haunt
Wilson F into feeling like he was a
rabbit in a snowstorm throughout his
life and I'm sure these details are
going to be debated endlessly in certain
Corners online but the implication is
that Wilson Fisk beating his father to
death with a hammer is a cannon event to
the sacred timeline of the MCU and the
Hawkeye series focused on fisk's
cufflinks and Wilson Fisk wears these
cufflinks because they belong to his
father and his mother gave them to him
after they both moved the corpse I know
so taking Brad W bomb at his word that
Marvel students now considers the
Netflix shows to be Canon and that
debate is behind us what does this mean
exactly from 2015 to 2019 Netflix
released 13 Seasons all of which
interconnected with each other and
presented themselves as taking place on
the street level of the MCU Daredevil
season 1 released in April 2015 Jessica
Jones season 1 released in November 2015
darville season 2 released in March 2016
Luke Cage season 1 released in September
2016 Iron Fist season 1 released in
March 2017 The Defenders which was an 8
episode crossover series released in
August 2017 The Punisher spin-off season
1 released in November 2017 Jessica
Jones season 2 released in March 2018
Luke Cage season 2 released in June 2018
Iron Fist season 2 released in September
2018 and around this time Netflix
actually started to cancel these shows
so we got Daredevil season 3 its final
season released in October 2018 The
Punisher season 2 released in January
2019 and Jessica Jones season 3 released
in June 2019 and I don't think people
properly realize how much runtime this
amounts to compared to the runtime
people previously understood the MCU to
be I actually started breaking this down
in my deep dive video about Marvel's
removed story lines last year and how
much total runtime increased drastically
from 2019 to 2021 and then to 2022 so
with the help of John and Brandon and a
handy spreadsheet created by Reddit user
YX kuo we went back through everything
so Marvel phase 1's total runtime of
films from 2008 through 2012 amounted to
12 hours and 24 minutes you know Iron
Man Hulk Iron Man 2 Thor cap in the
first Avengers film Marvel Phase 2 total
runtime of films from 2013 to 2015 and
this isn't including the Marvel one
shots or the ABC shows or the Netflix
shows that amounted to 12 hours and 38
minutes Marvel phase 3's total runtime
of films from 2016 through 2019 this is
just the MCU movies during this time 24
hours 57 minutes this is when they
started doing three movies a year and
then endgame was like super long Marvel
phase 4 though with streaming series
added to the mix 2021 through 2022 56
hours and 46 minutes and now starting
2023 with Antman the was Mania through
this current week in January 2024 Marvel
Phase 5 total runtime so far 24 hours
and 52 minutes so the grand total of run
time of what has previously been
considered MCU Canon all the MCU films
and Disney plus streaming shows special
present ations anything overseen by
Kevin feig's vision of Marvel Studios
amounted to a total of 131 hours and 37
minutes that's about 5 and a half days
of content and if that sounds like a lot
it is but hold on to your butts because
we total the full runtime of the Netflix
shows remember 13 Seasons folks and
oftentimes these are 13 episodes per
season 50 mey minutes per episode as
opposed to like Disney plus where it's
like hey we're going to do six episode
seasons and it's going to be like 35
minutes and then 10 minutes of that it's
going to be the credits so if you were
to add just the shows where D daril
Charlie Cox appears and so far only he
and vinent denafo Wilson visk have been
confirmed to return for future Marvel
Studios titles maybe John Bernthal as
well but Daredevil seasons 1 through
three and the Defenders makes up 41
hours and 12 minutes of additional
runtime and if you were to add all the
interconnected Netflix Marvel titles
Luke agage Jessica Jones Punisher
Defenders Iron Fist Daredevil all of it
comes to 142 hours in 25 minutes which
is about six full days so through this
annexation if you want to call it that
Marvel Studios has effectively more than
doubled its runtime of canonical
storytelling it added to its current 5
and 1/2 days of stories another 6 days
it's the Louisiana Purchase of cinematic
expansions thank you to better help for
sponsoring this video A new year is a
great excuse for finally tackling the
stuff that you put off last year and if
one of the things you've been putting
off until 2024 is taking proper care of
your mental health better help can help
you get started and hey no judgment for
waiting starting therapy can be hard and
the right therapist for you might not be
in your area and some people struggle
with the face- Toof face interaction of
therapy with with better help you can
have your therapy sessions as a phone
call as a video chat or even via
messaging if you prefer that whatever is
the most comfortable version of therapy
for you just click the link in the
description and answer a few questions
about what you're looking for from
therapy and what your preferences are
better help will then match you with the
therapist from their Network that's
right for you if you don't really fit
with that therapist which is a common
thing with therapy you can easily switch
to a therapist for no additional cost
without stressing about insurance who is
in your network or anything like that if
you think you might benefit from therapy
consider betterhelp click the link in
the description or visit betterhelp.com
rockstars clicking that link helps
support this Channel and also gets you
10% off your first month of better help
so you can connect with a therapist to
see if it helps you now you could say
well hey Marvel Studios has already been
doing this by bringing in Toby McGuire
Andrew Garfield and Spider-Man no way
home bringing in Patrick Stewart Charles
Xavier and Anon Mount blackold and
Doctor Strange's Multiverse Madness
Kelsey gramar beast in the Marvels Hugh
Jackman Wolverine in the upcoming
Deadpool 3 sure sure that's all true but
those appearances have so far been
considered multiversal crossovers from
different universes that are separate
from the MCU continuity Wilson fist
Kingpin has so far been implied to been
part of the MCU sacred timeline since
the beginning that's what makes this
latest confirmation so significant so
what happened in these additional 142
and 1 half hours what story lines were
left unresolved that the MCU will now
have to address well there is so much to
go through and trust me new rockstars is
going to get to all of these shows on
the channel in the next couple years but
for Daredevil season 3 showed Matt
Murdoch battling Wilson Fisk as Kingpin
Unleashed Ben Point texter an expert
Marksman with mental health struggles to
impersonate Daredevil and Destroy
Daredevil's reputation murog exposed B's
involvement in the death of Point
Dexter's love which sends Point Dexter
on a killing spree against everybody and
he actually instes it receiving bionic
augmentation to become Bullseye it's
crazy and that's where it leaves off but
the more satisfying conclusion is when
Murdoch Corners Wilson fist with
evidence that could get Vanessa in
prison Fisk after a bloody brawl lets
himself get taken in so in addition to
Daredevil season 3 ending with Fisk
incarcerated Daredevil Born Again has
recast Vanessa from Al at zuro to
sandreen Holt so that's going to have to
be explained or maybe it just never will
be Luke Cage ends with perhaps the
biggest Cliffhanger of these series
Mariah Dillard had left the ownership of
Harlem's Paradise nightclub to Luke Cage
who appoints himself the sheriff of
Harlem part of Mariah's plot to drag
Luke into her world of corruption Luke's
friend DW even calls him Luke Trump yeah
that's right A lot of these shows
reference Trump and American electoral
politics which Ekko also kind of did
with that make America skate again sign
meanwhile the MCU has established
fictional presidents like Matthew
Ellison president britson from Secret
invasion in Luke Cage Mersa Ali played
Cornell Stokes and now MERS Ali is going
to be playing blade in the MCU Mariah
was played by Alfre Woodard who also
played The Grieving mother Miriam sharp
in Captain America Civil War then again
Jim andan played both minurva and
Captain Marvel and Cersei in eternals
Michelle yo played Alita ogord in
Guardians Volume 2 and yingan and Shang
XI so you know double castings aren't
entirely unprecedented in The Punisher
series season two shows Frank Castle
finally scoring Vengeance against Billy
Russo jigsaw and the Gang responsible
for his family's death his ally hacker
David liberman micro is played by Evan
Moss pakro from the bear now rumored to
have a role in the upcoming Fantastic 4
in the Iron Fist series Daniel Rand
gives up the mantle of the Iron Fist to
Colleen Wing becomes a New York vigilan
in her own right channeling her power
through her Katana meanwhile Dany and
Ward go to Asia on a quest and months
later seems like Danny has regained some
of the powers the Iron Fist but the
fullest conclusion was perhaps on
Jessica Jones who spent all of season 3
trying to reign in her former best
friend and sister figure Trish who has
now become the violent super vigilante
of Hellcat Trish gets incarcerated at
the raft and the series ends with
Jessica headed to Mexico but the voice
of David tenant's amazing villain of
killgrave returns in her mind taunting
her for running and so Jessica decides
to stay in New York presumably to keep
working cases for her Alias
investigations now the defender season
was really a middle season for most of
these series like in between one and two
for most of them in between season 2 and
three for Daredevil in the show we saw
the heroes joining forces under Matt
Murdoch's Mentor stick in order to fight
the hand which was an evil organization
led by Sigourney Weaver as Alexandra
their goal was to resurrect Electra naos
as black Sky it dealt with a massive pit
beneath New York City this is really the
closest any of these shows came to an
Avenger level threat in my opinion most
of the time what made these shows great
is that they were dealing with Rogue
killers on the loose in Hell's Kitchen
in the broader New York area and the
fact that these Heroes dealt primarily
with street level conflicts and legal
cases makes them pretty easy to fit into
the history of the MCU that's how the
producers of these shows intended them
to be and I think Fisk referencing his
past with his dad and the hammer and the
peeling pain on the wall and we'll see
maybe Matt Murdoch referencing his past
with the chemical spill his father's
boxing his too L from stick that might
be as far into their backstories these
Disney plus MCU shows go but remember
there are so many Side characters and
subplots to fill all those 13 episode
seasons and if Daredevil Born Again
tries to do what Ekko did and flash back
to dates like 2007 2008 2015 or whatever
that was so much was going on during
Daredevil and Jessica Jones Luke Cage
ironfist Defenders and Punisher during
the years of 2015 2016 2017 Fisk being
incarcerated sometimes but really the
fact that Fisk was an unknown power
broker in New York City at other times
whose grunts would violently kill kill
themselves upon giving up just his name
how could he also be a public figure
that anybody knows at any time before
that it's just inevitably going to do
those series of disservice for the
Disney plus MCU shows to try to revisit
or rehash that history too much in my
opinion the smartest move to make would
be to flash back to an unexplored Era of
the MCU that's been Untouched by
anything including the Netflix series
2018 to 2023 the blip remember ekko's
father died during the blip we got to
revisit that history when Ronin killed
him these shows should go back to those
years and tell new stories about what
Fisk and Murdoch Frank Castle and the
rest were doing in the New York City
area where Boats were mored at Liberty
Island cars were abandoned at City
Fields I want to hear Wilson FIS
screaming from the Brooklyn Bridge at
the Wales and the Hudson and by the way
for the Agents of Shield die hards who
want their division of Marvel
storytelling from the ABC run to be
confirmed as Canon next or just be
confirmed because in their head it
already is Canon and you have an
argument if you add up all seven seasons
of Agents of Shield we're talking 22
episode Seasons there plus two seasons
of Agent Carter plus that one season of
Inhumans that would add an additional
114 hours and 38 minutes of runtime you
also got the Marvel series runaways on
Hulu three seasons of that which would
bring an additional 26 hours and 32
minutes of runtime then you also have
the Marvel series Cloak and Dagger on
free form two seasons of that an
additional 14 hours and 4 minutes we
could keep going with this but just with
the ones I mentioned this is a growing
Multiverse so in the recent MCU timeline
book which omits the Netflix shows the
ABC shows and all other Marvel
continuities leaving them out of the
Sacred timeline Kevin feig's WI wink
note in that book that other timelines
could in the future be retconed in
potentially tripled the size of the MCU
as we know it let me know your thoughts
on all this down below you can subscribe
to all three channels in the new rock
stars Network please follow me at eaos
support us by grabbing some merch From
Nerd rot. shop thanks for watching and
I'll see you next time
bye